American
we are back in the gentleman Jojo
stronger than ever Rip's angry ready I
chaired my shirt off right now ah man I
don't know I'm Jackie due to the met
brother no I don't know if I'm saving of
him walking down the islands of the ring
or his sex date I'm trying to think
which what I masturbated to bar why what
happened holster and what happened
Hulkster by the way real American writ
by Rick Dillinger Regehr injure sorry
Bert derringer which song was better
seeing Hogan go down the aisle to the
ring to that one or eye of the tiger
topics this one no no no no no I the
Tigers Rocky dude that's his song let's
let our guests decide let's let our
guest this night is you're on the phone
yeah he's on the phone our guest today I
can't believe this is the first time
we're having him on because we love this
guy literally catechin I intro or you
let's tag team intro those British
bulldogs this okay you started off and
I'll k i'll bring it home which birds
full dog are you I'm Davey Boy Smith I'm
the other one dynamite kid yeah um there
you go I'm the other one I love you can
you kick it off you kick it on I guess
well he has I guess I'm special there's
a podcast right here on this network on
I heard a pc i've heard of it it's
called good times i've been a guest I
that should be called great I've credits
yeah okay I think it should be called
great times too yeah I like it a lot
yeah but he's we take a notch he's a big
fan of jimmy walker in that TV show when
they were living in the hood so that's
where its name or something is that
what's not have no real intro you peace
i just said he's got a podcast on the
network in that you said you were gonna
dynamite kid in go ahead all god ok this
guy literally is not only I gotta tell
you when I when I bring some guys on the
road with me you know I don't always
watch them that be you are there other
times where I sit back and I become uh
like a comedy fan again I worked with
this gentleman recently in
ampa and there's something that's
happened I think the last year or two
where he's just gone on another level
and I absolutely i think his stand ups
[ __ ] awesome but on top of that he's
like the greatest guy in the world and I
have to we're gonna play this for him
well we control ladies and gentlemen
from the good times podcast he's a great
Stan Utley he's from Philadelphia
Pennsylvania he's an incredible stand up
a great comic a better human being the
nicest man from Philadelphia
Pennsylvania Steve somehow what's up
Simone how are you I know awesome thanks
for coming in the next hangout man well
by the way by the way Simone's probably
doing like a toy drive somewhere today I
mean this guy this guy's always doing
something for the kids he's donating
blood he's doing something you do so
much work with the Children's Hospital
Los Angeles I'm a father of two and I
feel guilty i'm like oh maybe I should
hang with my kids today yeah but like
Simone is literally going to the
hospital getting them chucky cheese
party as doing like toy drives and these
kids are getting like it not just like
they're not getting like a teddy bear
they're getting like real like flying
drones and stuff Simone honestly like
you're unbelievable how did your let's
just start talking about that Jones
house how did you get started with with
with the grade with the great work at
Children's Hospital um I just saw people
that needed help and nobody was really
helping so I just did whatever I could
do and amazing how other people come
through i don't really do anything then
I just let people know their kids out
there that need help and it's amazing
how the world comes out to help I mean
but you see I had everything you're
doing blood drives you're doing toy
drives I mean um oh I I don't know i'll
give all the food in the world to
another comic in pro wrestling canvas
guide me Jeremy lobster claw there's a
few years ago what I I heard about a
little
accident two years ago WrestleMania it's
worth I saw through kid in my older
brothers neighborhood that was a
wrestling fan and had a rare disease and
I came back to Wrestlemania min realized
I didn't have enough stuff to send me
get you know like I was just looking at
the box of things I wanted to look care
package it just make this kids oh the
struggle he was going through a little
more enjoyable you know and I said you
know it's not enough so i turn the
social media was the first because i
don't really like like I think some for
charity work and stuff should be more
private but you know what constantly
it's the short lengths people will
kidnap your need help nobody will help
well yeah yeah it's a social media and I
said hope there's a little hey I got
some through all the people on this
really great rowdy Piper was like I know
it's and wrestling people on in my
social media networking today there's a
very sick little boy that that you
journaling fan I want to send the
mackeir package and it was amazing how
everybody stepped up to help and if off
it was a titleist my podcast took his
kids to toys r us we cleaned up the
wrestling section guys like Stephen
pointing from the conference or skype a
buddy that works for the WWE and then
John Austin was like I can get you this
system this and say hey I also do some
volunteer Children's Hospital and that's
that that part starting well right down
there to see a blood drive because they
desperately need blood so if you're in
the los angeles area i just want to give
you their phone number yeah you can't
donate blood ah their numbers 3 2 336 1
2 441 for the blood blood donor center
at Children's Hospital and now within I
met a great guy down until possible that
that his job is getting blood me my
buddy Raul and that was it I started to
blood drives and they start to become
friends with some of the families down
there and just turn it helped but you're
such a nice guy I know that it's Steve
went to do one of these drives he would
just show up at Children's Hospital with
a bunch of his DVDs you'll hey kid who
wants
champion I mean like he would put no
effort in to go to Toys R Us he just
pass out that [ __ ] and make those kids
more miserable okay yeah anyways I tell
you you could that I'm up that bad joke
went nowhere haha that's local amnon
season four okay hey so let me just
watching Gary I'm okay yeah right balls
and I love how you know I knew Gary for
years before I knew he had a black belt
in fall break nice to be I was scary
cavender uh so we wanted so what we see
here's what we're gonna say this request
before before we get the meat and
potatoes of the show go do me a favor
you're listening to the dojo right now
you are you are here every week at the
dojo with us I could not stress this
enough go to iTunes right now and
download remember this by Steve Simone
it's 999 it's literally one of the
funniest standup albums you'll hear and
it will make you reflect to all those
good times thus the podcast name and he
just hits a nerve nobody's doing what
Simone is doing there you go back in
time and recollect about all those
positive great childhood memories and
ice I sit in the back and I watch him
tell these stories you know these
personal stories that everybody can
relate to and you just see the audience
all looking at each other or high-fiving
each other I haven't seen that type
response since my last special taping um
but honestly do me a favor download
remember this you will thank me later
it's [ __ ] awesome go ahead Carrie I'm
sorry to interrupt and and if you
download happy hour that was your second
one there's a $25 mail-in rebate Gary
Jesus Christ now let's get let's get to
the crux of why why we have Simone here
by the way I do i do love I mean there's
there's you know obviously we all grew
up
watching wrestling back I think when it
was so much better than it is negative
right so much better but do you still so
Steve for audience who does not know is
a huge huge wrestling fan and
WrestleMania is this Sunday now as a fan
of wrestling will you get it or were you
are you not as interested in it anymore
as you once were uh I'm very
disappointed with the current product
and the only reason I'm disappointed
with the current product is because I
love it so much yeah except it's like if
I didn't care i just want to care i
doing that whatever I outgrew it but uh
it's just it's just not good it was so
much better when we were kids but that's
because when you're a kid you believe it
right cuz im looking 41 and I have a lot
of friends that still love wrestling and
I'm like but why wouldn't you just watch
UFC where it's real and they do not like
each other like when you're young it's
it's fun it's a soap opera for kids but
then you get older you're like well it's
something different and why you still
into the ship there is this believable
okay when we're kids you look good for
41 there is this shuttle Ibaka by the
way it's right Steve it's hard to
believe it's WrestleMania 32 right uh
yeah and it's going to be in dallas in
dallas don't poke Steve Austin's coming
back right we don't know what he's going
to do but uh I'd will watch it but this
will be I don't think I've really wow
okay this is my bad wrestling stuff in
my opinion that the last time I really
watch Tristan was at WrestleMania last
your gay bro places in same as I would
like yeah and then I got back into
briefly in my kitchen if not it's not
being handled properly if I opinion the
creative aspect of it the reason why we
thought it was real when we were kids
wasn't just because we were kids but
because the ways uh the way we were
doing was sold was that the matches are
important and you cared about good guys
versus bad guys we enter text post
modern era holds the inside here working
and I was good or bad and there are two
great wrestling personality so we're
able to do that amazingly you had the
rock and Stone Cold Steve Austin that
added to your de my opinion was last
great period of pro wrestling but once
you took away the fact that the masses
didn't matter and it wasn't no there was
no longer story of good vs evil because
what may be a bad guy bad guy Damini for
the fact it's what she twin right you
would keep you in like rowdy Piper and
you know well Yeah right right i loved
it the wrath or ever the ref was looking
giorgia hits in 80 people are talking to
turn around a thousand people are gonna
turn around I haven't seen that bad
acting since Gary kanima right Russ
Lee's gotten so bad TBS is buying it
okay [ __ ] you burn I didn't want to go
that way right you just gave me a bio
driver but you're saying it used to be
because because guys were just bad they
were just bad right but they always had
like it like Elizabeth wasn't she with
it was awesome man she was with macho
man and I was like why is this beautiful
one with this bad guy but like Hulkster
never had like a chick with him and so
was kind of cool to be bad by the way by
the way it was so funny I remember years
and years ago when when the Iron Sheik
finally lost the belt to Hogan this was
years and years ago and I remember
Freddie Blassie was his manager that I
remember backstage they're being
interviewed by Mean Gene and Freddie
Blassie said the reason Hogan one is
because that referee is his uncle that
member the guy that the referee was rich
Hebner or something like that right and
I gotta tell you as a kid you're like
why the hell would his uncle ref a match
between his nephew and the Iron Sheik
yeah it's believable I mean you're like
I can't believe that Freddie blast sees
the guy calling this out it means like I
truly believe or you see on the voice of
reason
well yes here's what I just think oh go
ahead see I think you made a great point
as to what the difference was between
the product and in the product now you
mentioned Mean Gene Okerlund and to me
that's what I think I was a little kid
means you talk to move d backstage and
he would interview the bad guy at no
point were those guys near each other
good guys and bad guys fit the only time
they were lost each other was in the
Marine right because you believe they
wanted to kick each other's ass now your
progress more guys are not there's no
warning there's no more buffer between
the combatants so these guys standing
holding microphones just giving speeches
or soliloquies while the guys I'm gonna
kick your butt and skating so angry
right now right I'm so angry but I'm
gonna stay here of them like kick each
other this is that all right that's like
the eight-year-old in you like that's
the eight-year-old rationalizing at all
so that's the problem now is because I
don't watch it like you to like you
watch it Gary yet not as much but yeah a
little bit Simone you watch it I know
like you you went like with Gabriel
Iglesias like Gabriel Iglesias is super
into it and he's got his crew into it
and I'm just like you guys were 40 what
[ __ ] like I don't wet work to me I don't
mean to be the devil's advocate but what
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you guys
like Batman vs Superman I'll go see that
[ __ ] it's a movie it's yeah it's comic
book sitting it's not it's only I'm not
like I hope you know I hope that I can't
even name a wrestler these days I have
no idea I couldn't name you one I could
care less yeah you know what okay good
night in the best is on the indie
circuit right now good oh here we go
you're the hipster of wrestling now no
hello Natasha damn i would go with
halter 600 this thing called pro
wrestling guerrilla and they
complete suspension of disbelief there's
something that if that can happen when
Roddy Piper once tell me like the
greatest thing is like when a pro
wrestler gets hit with a real shot and
somebody's watching the match we go
that's not real wait that's real wait I
think this guy's really mad right now
that you would work get get into it like
I think some of the stuff because of the
internet access to informational people
of both the real-life drama behind the
scenes right I will get lost for hours
from youtube and listen to like old
Harley Race shoot interview mother
stories about you know king haku being
the toughest guy ever to walk the earth
that guy how cool yeah did they said
like he was once in a bar fight and I
broke some guy's jaw off you're like
reaching was now and find his jaw he did
it like King Kong Kong movie where he
opened the too much his mouth and split
it open yeah I get your point we go it's
just stupid this is all fake but there's
there's a something that can happen with
foreign thing and it doesn't happen
often anymore but when it works it's the
coolest form of entertainment there is
when it works it's because it's part
movie it's rock concert it's part baths
letak event it's really really cool they
need to make it more about what happens
in the rain and what's going on well
look I think because everything's a
reality show now you know they have that
WWE like divas on E right yeah so that's
drama that fuels into the matches i'm
sure i have no idea i'm just guessing is
that correct or any guys in their 40s
years ago we had the Fabulous Moolah
that we beat off to but what I remember
but but but but it's interesting so by
the way bit because I before we me rush
out of time I really want to get to this
because you know you were a big big
wrestling fan as a kid and just watched
it and you know just knew everything
inside now like I did and then you know
you fast-forward years later you know
here's this little kid from Philly that
now lives in LA and you become really
good friends with rowdy roddy piper like
how does that whole dynamic come
together and you know obviously when he
passed away that to be just you know
huge void for you I mean like how does
that yeah how does that whole thing come
together and how does that you know as a
little kid who just was up a piper I
remember I just met him one time and
that was a bucket list item for me and
he was a guy that you hated as a kid but
you still like there's some cool about
him you know I mean you never like truly
hated well Roddy Piper you were still
like he's a he's like a good bad guy
does that make sense yeah even as a kid
I picked up on that so it's crazy
because here you are and you move you
come out to LA and how does the whole
you know divine intervention yeah well
say first i'll say this burn makes a
great point about wrestling for ticks I
all get to its for do you don't I mean
yes but I think it could be the type of
entertainment if it's so fun you can
enjoy it on different levels throughout
your life like when you're eight you're
like this is Marie all by the time I got
to college like this your sister that's
that's so as I I remember on the first
phone call right for years 800 I can you
leave your house when you go to your
friends you know in blender ten years
old you're not like okay do you want one
you want to meet up live in three
minutes know your thoughts I'd like I'm
a point things can get a lot of phone
calls you don't need a phone with your
left but I remember watching Saturday
morning my mom I need to use the phone
matter like i gotta call brian and
they're gonna call my buddy Brian moss
or might be watching this this ball
cipher guy some have to stop them like I
know I know I know you believe this [ __ ]
these are two guys all to God these are
two little boys exclamation
didn't care about girls so right if you
bring the lotion next time oh the reason
why forward is so enjoyable for me as a
kid would be cause of Roddy Piper great
when you're little you just root for
them you wanted to go to beat up the bad
guy right because I would almost peed
mistress without the bad guy so I
remember going to the Hall of Fame
induction ceremonies I guess I like
about 10 years ago maybe 11 years ago
what WrestleMania was in LA and all in
one night hi Coco just rotting fight for
the Iron Sheik Nikolai Volkoff they all
got essentially my childhood got stuff
it into the WWE hall of fame competitors
for myself one and our tickets were so
far away from the stage if it gets an
amplitude which seems like 6,000 people
we were literally in the last row
touching the ceiling what I mean so do I
had I was so broken we had enough money
for one teacher and I was like you know
what I'm not going to get Logan I'm not
gonna I'm gonna get the paper shirt and
Brett was like no I'm Joe hot rod sir I
can't believe they have it i'm getting
120 we bought Piper shirt and then like
23 years later I got a call from Eric
Abrams out the UH called what you
probably was like I'm putting the other
show a present running place where do
you want to be a part of it I was like
oh absolutely did a show together in
that night we just became buddies like
today I was at the time of do me comics
that had referenced assist material yeah
did you write that stuff for tonight I'm
like no it's big right thats a great
main event stuff tonight question about
this down and what what kind of show was
Piper doing at the time Steve like what
was he doing he was trying to figure it
out to be honest with you um yes I think
was going to like headline that show but
then decided to like empty
you're right and he was experimenting
with different jokes and different
different approaches to comedy and
that's how we really became friends
because his manager at the time Noel was
like uh why he was really impressed with
your comedy anything to tell oh I was a
nice guy you know and she was like he
wants to come see perform comedy again
yeah so that uh Roddy came to the comedy
store and everybody was nuts and then
after that night he invited me up to his
house and he was like do you want to
help me put together an act oh man yeah
how crazy is that do it I mean is the is
like the eight-year-old in philly in you
just like how did this happen this is
why I moved to Los Angeles by the way by
the way it's it's it's rowdy Piper it's
not like leaping Lanny Poffo invited you
to his studio and rissa Coco beware not
Hacksaw Jim I mean this is like a low
sure it's true ya XO is pretty awesome
this is rowdy like this a big deal yeah
yeah I mean you think about the event
induction class it's Hulk Hogan Iron
Sheik Nikolai Volkoff and roddy roddy
piper i mean if i thought back to my
childhood it's like those and Andre the
Giant would be the would be the five
guys I would think about out of the
gates you're great yeah and then you're
cool thing this is I I lost a job over
and I was cuz i was working for Courtney
Vegas when exactly combinatorial fires
for the show right poor can't can't make
it to Vegas Vegas okay what's going on
okay makiaa it's yeah the prolific all
feeding know why why can't you mean
their own Hall of Fame which children
pills and Ric Flair is the one that
introduced Piper and svet sir Stallone
is the one that stole get oh wow like
the greatest night in so then how does
it work then steal them you go up to
Piper's house right yep and then and
then what happens from there I me cuz
that's just a just so I mean are you
just driving up to the surreal yeah
that's all time because meeting somebody
aquatic Piper the first time it's kinda
like meeting a comic book character and
I mean it in the best sense of the word
like those guys anybody that makes an
impression upon which I think makes it
impress upon you as a kid they hold a
special place in your heart and a
special place in your like in your
psyche there more than kuna and
especially for me which I look at his
pro wrestling for me as it gets kind of
like comic books for a kid that didn't
like to read I didn't like to read but I
got the scene sort of comic book my
younger brother goes read xmas and stop
spider me and I was a sort of turn to
read I can't do it but I'd watch my
perspective versus evil every Saturday
morning does that make sense yeah that
was your old one so so when I met Piper
I'm like you seem like a real to the big
butt looks like improve this guy's real
yeah so then um in his house and the
truth was and i wrote a joke about this
but like I'm hanging out with them and
I'm like this is amazing this is cool
the reason why he wanted he came up to
me after he told me to format the comedy
circus owner said about babysitting my
niece at a time is having an invisible
tea party and I forgot yep paper was
even in the audience and then I was what
are you doing you're talking about a
freaking invisible team the toughest guy
ever down the crowd that's amazing like
me he survived three dollars i can tell
you're good guy you know all you want to
come by my house and spoke about making
put back together so now i'm hanging out
with this guy who says he's got kids and
he's a nice person in them but my inner
11 year old was still talking my inner
11 rows like i don't think you should
trust them remember what he could do
Jenny superfest yes so bad I know right
but it wasn't cold never had this the
most amazing life experience um that
that was just I mean I just miss him so
much because it's so much more could
have shared with us like the guy lived
literally a thousand line
so what I would sit at his feet he just
start telling me stories he said oh I
don't have anything Institute was the
time I got high with the ninjas wanted
he had stories like that he had just
about getting trampled on for the giant
get storybook getting into legit bar
fights because back in the 70s and 80s
when he was coming up professional
wrestling was was not family
entertainment like he works for
promoters that if you got beat up
outside the ring you lost your job and
he works for promoters that we encourage
professional wrestlers to start bar
fights and he was so hated and people
took it so seriously in his era that you
would have to pay like the cook at
dennys 20 bucks vs. fitness food and
would have to go back in the kitchen
once the guy make it oh wow people
wanted to kill him he was stabbed three
times somebody he had a get a special
jacket made so in case he got stabbed
again in places where he could hide at
dawn and today it was a whole different
with a whole different error and I
didn't realize that like guys his era
where the UFC stars of their time yeah
like that was probably the biggest thing
I learned from hyper like because when i
was little i thought it was one hundred
percent real that summers in the soul I
team to the policemen are one hundred
percent stake when how much percent
stuns me in fake and then now almost be
a pin joint this is a free line like
some respect for rotties generation like
he was legitimately trained by this guy
named judo gene LeBell who's a martial
arts legend to was the guy that you know
talked Bruce Lee have it to grapple guys
only issued like 21 black belts one was
to the Bruce Lee another monster truck
parts another woman's to Roddy Piper you
know like a guy is considered
grandfather min a and I really do but I
believe Julia whiten Giglio I got one as
well level of realism again and I think
we're all teach with who's come on well
I remember that you you did a show
literally I think a month or two
before Ronnie had passed add meltdown
was like pizza and wrestling right some
like that yeah it was uh this is how
cold God is the first night I ever met
Ronnie was captured on film that show we
did at the improv back in like two
thousand nine or something like that and
then the last night i got to see ronnie
was back in the end of june start a must
be fun test and that was all sermons to
was the only live podcast I've ever done
it was like what if we threw a pizza
party and Ronnie writing paper that's
right yeah and we did it in a comment
the most fun day ever and that's what
was unbelievable that you got to share
that experience I have that and you know
Roddy has that moment in time obviously
before he left us all and you know it
thank you so much for sharing all this
but I gotta tell you too it's like it's
crazy because you watch like that Iron
Sheik documentary sure and there's a new
Jake the snake Roberts documented it's
coming out and you you know you watch
the wrestler with Mickey work and you
just realize it you know especially as a
stand-up comic we tour we travel we see
the dark side of humanity I think at
times you know on gasps Friday Saturday
Sunday nights these guys live a much
different I mean it's it's incredible
the lives they've lived especially that
iron sheik one it is so depressing and
heart-wrenching to see what's become of
our heroes or these like you'd like you
had like you said these superhero
villains that over time I don't know it
just like it really makes me appreciate
what they gave us and what they gave her
childhoods especially because for those
that what was it Sunday's right is when
it was always on Saturday mornings it
was a kid we had it saturday morning uh
who's after all the cartoons right yep
yes after cartoons for a point and then
you had 22 Championship Wrestling on TBS
when we got tables came on around five
thirty miss pics on Saturdays and then
when the WWF really started expands
gaming Titans and then all came on but
even like when you're talking about
Roddy getting that like that Jay that
special jacket so he could get stabbed
like I wonder what that does to a man
psyche especially at that time when
everybody was watching wrestling it just
seemed like it was a pop culture kind of
phenomenon WrestleMania nothing and
nothing like we grew up with
WrestleMania but before r estimated
there wasn't a Wrestlemania there wasn't
any of that right and then all the
sudden guys Hulk Hogan Roddy Piper and
Andre they made wrestling what it is and
I can't imagine being like the bad guy
going out in public knowing that kids
hate you like did he ever aggress
anything like that yeah that's gonna do
something crazy to an adult syrup mine
like with the third podcast I ever did
Ronnie came over to my apartment is he
just honey said oh sorry will vulnerable
it was dude he told me he made this
great distinction about all the stuff
we're talking about it was like the guys
that had for us was now he's like
everybody understands essentially that
their planes Park right he was like you
know Mick Foley could come out me Mick
Foley he could be cast as charity dude
loves and everybody knew that he was
there's an entertainment area too it was
like I was rathi pray for 24 7 he was
like there was no distinction flood how
the people perceived me as a human being
and perceived Musil wrestler so people
would start fights with and they had to
live that life and toll it was to take
him but I don't know once in some Lykke
you have to like to beat people up and
stuff like that and see out with his
kids geez you know it was brutal yeah
cuz you time as an entertainer you're
going into wrestling just thinking I got
to put food on the table I got a family
it's like okay well you're gonna be a
good guy and you happen to be a bad guy
it's like okay well that's the gig i'll
be a bad guy and you're going out you
just make it a check
you're probably having a beer with the
good guy after the match you can't tell
the general public that and the public
just thinks you're an [ __ ] right it's
gotta be quick and it's not just like a
town or city or this it's the world
thinks you're a bad guy yeah it yeah
awful I don't got real sad here but I I
like I mean Roddy and I used to do a
podcast together pull the rock pod and
it was awesome yeah cuz like was just
another excuse for hanging out neva
laughs with one of my heroes I never
once we did an episode with the legend
Hacksaw Jim Duggan who is hilarious and
so funny in Greece but he taught a
heartbreaking story a bit back in the
eighties he was like feuding with the
iron she's pretty actually everything
USA come out oh we have like to buy
foreign like a red wine little bit
better anyway he got busted in the car
partying with sheep like they were yeah
yeah and then like that she got drugs
and stuff again he was so embarrassing
it was the worst because we're skating
each other huge are we got busted that
meanwhile they're doing an Eiffel Tower
then I before in a holiday in public
public oh god the worst music oh no it's
even worse he's like I'm from a little
small town in upstate New York my dad's
the chief of police and I was um tell me
that here's again we get caught with
drugs in the car and that's so
embarrassing on the phone no because I
know gets worse like a bursting with
energy today before it was the key to
the city oh god oh my god people that
story on her part geez oh man well those
guys they I don't know it's like yeah
it's a job but I think that they
sacrificed so much more with your
occupation because the Iron Sheik he
addressed that in in the documentary as
well and just how he got fired didn't
eat that he got fired any it kind of
took the lid off of wrestling in terms
of letting you know hey this is real
this is not real it's it's fake and then
kids got to see it and it just and drugs
were involved in you're not thinking of
my heroes don't do drugs and yeah it's
uh it's all boring Steve I saw a picture
a couple days ago Bobby the brain Heenan
and it's just it's it's yeah sad to see
you know what what would he had lung
cancer all right I kicked my jaw answer
yeah he's fighting I I saw interim it
doesn't look like the same guy at all
it's so sad I know what if it's really
sad it was just demands like you burned
you make a good point it was just guys
to put food on the table yeah and like
guys like Nikolai Volkoff who escaped
communist Yugoslavia defected because he
hated communism and it said okay buddy
like he focused when he got nothing at
all day and I may be getting wrong years
ago but essentially she like was an
Olympic weightlifter smuggle that smoke
himself out of the country was like 11
walks in his pocket and then it's like
you hate communism but tell you you're
the Stasi communism yeah we always used
to when we would go to the matches Steve
we would try to get as close to the ring
as possible and then we were always
rooting for the bad guy so our whole
thing was like when when the good guys
would come around they would be the guys
slap in the hands like around the ring
and I just remember so many times like
they would come around like I remember
Hillbilly Jim high-five in him and he
looked right at me I gave them the
middle finger I'm like [ __ ] you Jesus
carry their their throne as they don't
know how to handle that right yeah and
then you know when they introduce like
you know Volkoff for the ship yeah we're
the ones standing for the national
anthem you should tell Billy Jim I just
I just remember like do you remember
obviously Barry Windham and mike rotundo
like yeah I haven't heard those names is
like eighth grade only can't they came
running around the ring and obviously
they're shaking hands cuz they're
fighting the she can Volkoff and I
again the second they're about to
high-five me Mike [ __ ] you Brian rotundo
that name just the name it sounds like
every guy that was the first a finger
girl in 7th grade oh you don't know
about Bronwyn Tonto yay fingered Stacey
kucharski back by the dumpster just
that's a great name right rut uh no Mike
Rotundo Barry Windham much oh yeah
Michael or whatever the [ __ ] yeah
haven't heard those name server oh yes
Wyatt have you have you met any other
wrestlers from that era Steve that were
just it was just amazing uh yeah I want
I would go out on this rotting they
would do stand-up shows but this
standard position does conjunction with
wrestling event so I remember this one
weekend in the walking we could stand up
on me then he'll assign a wrestling
engagement so I'd ride with him the
wrestling promoter in road warrior all
animal head of cauliflower dink angie
was I'm cuz road warriors for my
favorites a team dinner then Edwin
animal found out that I was a comedian
he just wanted to make me laugh they all
these amazing oh wow but you know it's
so funny say that sir george the animal'
steele his real name was Jim Meyers I
think was that true Steve's Jim Meyers
yeah she's got a book out too i still
need to get that book so what a teacher
he was a football coach at a school in
Madison Heights Michigan and this is
kind of remember when you know I got the
door open and exposing everything that
was fake but I remember somebody showed
me a yearbook of Jim Meyers with his
football team and he's standing there
like normal and you're like wait a
minute where's the green tongue and how
could he be standing there contained if
he's this crazy guy and so I remember at
the time we would call the school all
the time and be like can we talk to Jim
Meyers and they'd be like oh man hold on
a second and they would never patch us
through so I think wow so but he was
this guy you know
this crazy wrestler yeah and yet a
football coach on the side you know me
was just you know you and the door was
exposed but and i remember it was almost
a year ago that I got to meet Hogan and
Jimmy Hart at the airport in chicago
which was just and they were both super
nice they were both great tweeted a
picture yeah yeah yeah it was the the
great i remember being a kid and there
was a mall by us and the first celebrity
i ever met like as a kid as you're
growing up you're living your life yeah
you go to the great adventure ii me
captain america but the first actual
celebrity i ever saw my life was Tito
Santana sure by rebound oh yeah and he
had a sighting there and he shows up in
the get up and everything which I guess
today would be considered racist but
there was and I was like that's it was
there a line to me them all there was a
an enormous line it was like me and a
bunch of other you know eight-year-old
seven-year-old boys like getting to meet
him and uh and Ricky the dragon
steamboat they all were so it was pretty
awesome i got their autographs and you
know you take a picture and this is back
in the day window for you know you got
it you know you but I hope I got it auto
developed yeah yeah and what I would
have I would have loved in the day to
met Paul Orndorff I think are like a big
john studd or being just died yeah that
name I mean it doesn't get better than
that page on stuff that's us I remember
this is this it's no joke this is no
joke so some sometimes Steve we wouldn't
get tickets for the event we would go
down and hang out at joe louis arena and
we knew the doors where they would enter
you know and drive their cars into like
the artist entrance area so we were just
go hang out and we would just wait try
to get pictures and i'll never forget uh
Terry Funk and who is his partner Jimmy
Jack funk Dory funk Dory funk so they
literally this is no joke they're
pulling into the garage that the artist
entrance and Terry Funk has the Lone
Ranger mask on so it's like he didn't
want to expose his eyes like he's
literally wearing the Lone Ranger mask
and I just remember like going to see we
get pictures after you know they were
coming out and we you know you that's
when you kind of realized who was
[ __ ] to when like the bad guys would
oohs and be super cool and yeah like
you're like okay wait a minute you know
and I remember one time this is kind of
when I knew too we were inside the
wrestling match my brother took us and
you want to go in and when we came out
my brother said you're not gonna believe
this I just saw the Iron Sheik smoking
pot right around the corner and I'm like
you're feeling [ __ ] I just saw and I'm
like your fullest and you are not
telling me the truth like I really I
didn't want to believe it that he was
smoking weed and then it turns out here
all in a car with acts on Jim Doyle
Simone we can I thank you enough and we
gotta play I mean I gotta play this for
Simone because he's just you know every
author all good things come to an end I
guess come on we were asking what's
what's a better song for Hogan coming
out to the ring real American or I the
tiger it's a good chicken oh joy hey I
said I don't say that oh it was yeah did
you see the Hogan sex tape now Oh liar
yeah Simone where can i find you come to
keep well we love you download remember
this Simone is a huge van Halen fans who
are playing some van Halen to set him
off thank you so much for calling in
Simone and listen to his his podcast
good times at all things comedy Thank
You Simone thank you Steve all right
thank you guys uh we're telethon you
Gary canon comedy underscore cherry funk
by the way this might be the longest
podcast we've ever done it's been yeah
we've had long ones yeah that was it was
good though but that was fun it was fun
I'm hearing like like we're done
butterfl those like great names I
haven't heard those names forever fun so
awesome ah we hope you enjoyed our
wrestling episode with wrestling
aficionado and huge fans do you Simone
I find us all things comedy keep the
reviews coming in guys we appreciate it